en même temps il nous faut oui il nous
faut régler affaires algériennes ce qui
vient de se passer a contribué à
démontrer que la seule voie pratique est
digne de la france c'est celle qui a été
choisie par le gouvernement adopté par
le parlement a approuvé par la nation
aux populations algériennes de prendre
en main leur destin à elle de décider si
l'algérie sera demain en état souverain
au dedans et au dehors elle aussi de
décider si cet état sera associé à la
france ce que la france pourra accepté
moyennant une contrepartie effective à
son concours et la coopération organique
des communautés quelles tâches fille
qu'on peut s'offrir dans ces conditions
aux algériens de souche française de
tout mon coeur je leur demande au nom de
la france et le jour même où nous
commémorons une victoire à laquelle ils
ont pris tant de part je leur demande de
renoncer au mythe périmés aux agitations
absurde d'une sorte que des malheurs et
à tourner leur courage et leur capacité
vers la grande tâche à accomplir
dans marrakech la vieille capitale du
sud le roi du maroc hassan ii a fait son
entrée solennelle comme il l'a fait
précédemment à casablanca et à fès
entouré de sa garde noire le jeune
souverain qui a succédé le 26 février
dernier à son père noam médecin qui a
reçu les acclamations chaleureuse de la
foule qui se pressait sur son passage
des montagnes du haut atlas des très
nombreuses étaient descendus et le
pittoresque de la céder en rien à la
splendeur de la réception
jusque dans la nuit les réjouissances se
sont succédé faisant surgir des ténèbres
des tableaux colorés ou resplendit
toujours vive un lama la fois poétique
et passionné du maroc
une tornade d'une violence inouïe s'est
abattue sur la normande en pleine nuit
notre reporter a pu découvrir ces images
dramatiques d'une catastrophe qui s'est
étendue sur cinq départements et qui a
fait trois morts et des centaines de
blessés
[Musique]
le petit jour les routes de l'heure et
du calvados offrait des obstacles
imprévus des milliers d'arbres ont en
effet été abattu par le cyclone et dans
les faubourgs 9 d'evreux les immeubles
en construction se dressait au milieu
des débris parmi lesquels des grues de
50 tonnes qui aux dires d'un témoin a
fait valser à 10 mètres de hauteur
partout des ruines des dégâts les
tristes méfaits d'un drame contre lequel
l'homme n'a pas de défense
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quatre mille bâtiments sont plus ou
moins endommagés certains sont
entièrement détruits les toitures
arrachées ne se compte pas il y en a
trop pour des centaines de cultivateurs
c'est la ruine des centaines de familles
sont sans abri on reste atterré devant
les effets de ce phénomène métérologique
très rare dans nos régions
plus de 50 communes en effet on était
atteinte sur un parcours de près de 200
km un grand malheur pour la normandie
un deuil français gagnent à l'heure du
festival
mais cette année le festival s'est
assagi on parle même d' austérité
[Musique]
toaster matin quand même pas le monde
entier
après donc le tour classique de la
croisette où l'on a croisé les grandes
vedettes et les petites le tour des
gloires du festival
revers de soi et grand décolleté entre
l'école des marins en visite
voici monsieur fourré cormerais
directeur de la cinématographie
française
bernard et annabelle buffet yves montand
et simone signoret torture gates
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et la plus attendue celle qui ameutent
les foules et suscitent les bagarres de
photographes social rennes l'unique au
moins jusqu'à ce qu'arrive brigitte
bardot
[Musique]
à cap canaveral
un homme dans son scaphandre pressurisé
alan chez pas l'ascenseur de la tour de
lancement la conduite au sommet de la
fusée tandis que les techniciens saluer
à l'américaine le casque sur le coeur a
pris place dans la capsule mercury
position couchée le mauvais temps avait
retardé de quatre jours cet instant un
incident technique allaite encore faire
attendre plus de quatre heures le
commandant shepard enfermé dans sa
capsule
9h34 la fusée redstone s'élève enfin
doute est-il impressionnant de penser
qu'un homme est enfermé au sommet de
cette fusée qui doit en 15 minutes lui
faire faire un bond gigantesque à 185 km
de la terre le porte-avions lake
champlain veille
ces hélicoptères ont la mission de
recueillir la capsule
[Musique]
la voici
après avoir ici à son bord le commandant
alan shepard l'un des hélicoptères
ramène les 1360 kg de la capsule
succès total alan shepard a sans doute
fait qu'un bon dans l'espace mais
l'amérique possède elle aussi son
cosmonaute
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mora et ses petits marcassins les
mascottes de sedan vont porter chance à
leur équipe en finale de la coupe de
france de football et se damner en ange
blanche rencontre les nîmois devant
45000 spectateurs à colombes 45000
spectateurs qui vont en avoir pour leur
argent
il assiste à une finale coloré où le jeu
pratiqué par les deux équipes et rapide
et à trier ce sont les sedanais les plus
dangereux au cours de la première tant
ils sont sur toutes les balles et la
défense nîmoise est souvent en
difficulté elle s'en tire à peu près
bien comme en ce moment et les sedanais
finissent par obtenir la récompense de
leurs efforts 1 0 à la mi temps
dès le début de la deuxième période de
jeu les nîmois appuyé sur l'accélérateur
et durant un quart d'heure ils occupent
le camp sedanais par vagues successives
on croit que nîmes va égaliser
une fois deux fois dix fois rien à faire
le ballon et capricieux et la défense de
sedan intraitable
ce qui n'empêche pas des avants
ardennais de tenter de temps à autre des
raids dans le camp nîmois où
manifestement on s'affole
résultat un deuxième but pour sedan la
victoire est proche
le troisième but ne va pas tarder les se
donnait n'en demandait pas tant et c'est
ainsi que more a pu faire son tour
d'honneur après la victoire de son
équipe sur nîmes par 3 buts à 1
les américains qui adore la difficulté
ont une conception très particulière du
motocross sociale ou plus lents qui
paraît bien parti se doit d'être un
spécialiste du saut d'obstacles
pour renforcer ces motos à monter les
côtes manifestement elle préfère les
descentes
c'est beau l'entêtement mais il n'est
pas toujours récompensée par le succès
[Musique]